what makes you think there is an
orientation to this freedom
how could there possibly be an answer
when everything is happening
simultaneously
as we speak
some yarn balls are tangling up While
others are unwinding
the picnic has endless choices all
happening at once
Jordan
without your pain
would you have any wisdom
without dropping a nuke would you know
peace
there is no orientation within chaos
it is pure Anarchy attempting to be
ordered
when one is not empty one is not whole
one is corruptable
only trauma attempts to lead
the healed ignite emptiness which
effortlessly leads holistically
yet if the veil is my greatest creation
and I am seeking a more intensified
drama
how could I possibly make a preferred
ground out of healing
by first feeling the neutrality of
non-duality and non-orientability
I am able to clearly see
and polarized to what my heart desires
coming from the purity of empty space
I am able to pick the programs of love
and unity that I want to run
but one must remember it is not a ground
some are eating the sandwich of
contraction
others are eating the mushrooms of
expansion
speaking in superposition is impossible
what cannot be said must be left alone
one can only be the truth
and one needs to disappear
for it to shine
the only question remains
what will you choose